our nurse residency program is what
this grant project was about and halfway
through our first cohort we started to
notice
that they needed some more hands-on out
of the classroom
learning and that really led us to
think of this really cool escape room
idea
the groups meet once a month for four
hours
and i try to cover topics that they may
not have covered
in school or nursing orientation there
were
skills that we noticed they were lacking
out on the floor
that were related to patient safety and
their own safety
what is that you have you are not taking
these
there's a kind of a fun part to it where
it's you know i'm playing
a patient in that specific room but
you're also learning
as well and i think i think you it
really does hit home a lot more than
sitting in a lecture five oh it worked
this is actually one of the more
creative learning tools that we've done
and also it's
it's learning but it's also been nice to
uh get you
in a like cooperative fun environment
with your co-workers
it goes beyond sitting in a classroom
with people
and discussing getting to know them into
like we're actually interacting together
and working as a team
we're fortunate to have our mid-atlantic
region office
in pittsburgh the staff there
are just absolutely incredible they're
such wonderful resources
we are essentially the major outreach
arm of the national library of medicine
we are the
boots on the ground going into
libraries of all kinds including health
sciences libraries but also
public libraries school libraries
community-based organizations
we do a lot of promotion of our
available funding
we encourage potential applicants to
talk to us about projects
that they're thinking about before they
apply we do
grants and proposal writing training to
really teach
to the application we really want to
make sure that we're funding
successful applications that are going
to advance the goals of nlm
originally in my funding application i
hadn't
applied for funding for any escape room
materials or anything like that so
we were able to revise our grant part of
the way through and get funding for our
escape room which has been one of the
biggest parts of this project
this is a great example of a project
that
olivia had a fantastic idea to begin
with and then she heard more
from her target population and the
people here
and so she was super flexible about
then thinking about more creative ways
to meet their needs
and we were part of that discussion
because it's not like we just say here
here's your money and uh let us know in
a year how you've done
it's been really really successful um
honestly more than i ever could have
anticipated
the grant that i received was for a
year-long project and the year is out
so this really was seed money for
building up our nurse residency program
and it's opened so many doors for me
here and within the upmc system it
worked
perfect easy
[Music]